[Musik]
bundespräsident frank walter steinmeier
fordert einen sozialen pflichtdienst für
junge menschen am gardasee van sexuelle
übergriffe jugendlicher mit
migrationshintergrund auf junge frauen
statt russland drosselt nach angaben des
energiekonzerns gazprom die
gaslieferungen über die ostsee-pipeline
nord stream einst nach deutschland um
gut 40 prozent es gibt also viel zu
diskutieren und damit herzlich
willkommen schön dass sie eingeschaltet
haben so führte nach acht meine gäste
heute abend sind großartig sie können
sie auf eine spannende sendung freuen
zum einen welt autorin und publizistin
birgit kelle sie sagt ich verwehre mich
gegen islamophobie aber wo kommen wir
hin wenn man diese gewalt gegen frauen
nicht kritisieren journalist juca frau
blickt besorgt auf die gasleitungen und
ist der überzeugung putin christi
deutschen bach csu politikerin silke
laudert versteht nicht warum
bundesfinanzminister christian lindner
anstelle der schuldenbremse neu
kostenintensive projekte der ampel
unterstützt fdp-politiker tobias
bauschke wird ihr bestimmen wm
entgegentreten
parteivorsitzende hier leidenschaftlich
verteidigten der schätze ich auf jeden
fall mal ich bin gespannt mein name ist
nina schenk und ich freue mich heute an
ihren gastgeberin sein zu dürfen meine
these die dienstpflicht ist
freiheitsentzug ich habe es ja eben
schon angemerkt bundespräsident frank
walter steinmeier hält es für eine
grandiose idee menschen in deutschland
für einen gewissen zeitraum zwangsweise
in den dienst der gesellschaft zu
stellen jetzt kommt keine besonders
große überraschung linken-politiker bodo
ramelow ja auch der ist wie die soziale
dienstpflicht für junge menschen die
schulpflicht sei schließlich auch ein
zwang er frage sich deswegen mal nicht
da noch ein jahr mehr dazu definieren
können auch berlins bürgermeisterin
franziska giffey sorgt natürlich nicht
für eine überraschung sie hätten
sozialen pflichtdienst für sinnvoll sie
sagt wir leben in einer veränderten zeit
und vielleicht gehört zur zeitenwende
auch dass jeder junge mensch ein jahr
für die allgemeinheit aufbringen das
klingt ja jetzt jan etwas gutes tun für
die allgemeinheit aber lassen sie es
mich einmal vereinfacht ausdrücken die
dienstpflicht ist freiheitsentzug wir
brauchen eine zeitenwende die
zeitenwende zurück zur freiheit die
zeichen wenn er da hin dass es
individuum im mittelpunkt steht nicht
die gemeinschaft es gibt nichts schützen
wertes als die freiheit des individuums
zu der staat sollte nicht mehr macht
bekommen sondern sich endlich wieder aus
dem leben der menschen zurückziehen und
jetzt freue ich mich ganz besonders
darauf was georg k frau dazu sagt ich
bin weder ein verkappter kommunist noch
ein verkappter rechtsradikal ist ein
kommunist natürlich habe ja nicht nur
kommunistischen partei entschuldigen sie
bitte ja müsse das programm lesen da
wissen sie bescheid also kommunisten
oder rechts fertig habe ich bin nicht
beides aber ich bin dafür dass junge
leute auch nicht nur fordern können sie
wachsen immer freien
wohlstandsgesellschaft auf und die
haltung unserer vielen zeigen auch die
umfragen ist mit einer enormen förder
haltung und vorbehalten gegenüber dem
staat ich will alles und zwar sofort bin
aber nicht bereit wenn es nicht meine
eigenen nutzen dient etwas für die
gemeinschaft zu tun mit dieser haltung
hätten wir wieder die bundesrepublik
deutschland nach dem kriege aufgebaut
noch könnten wir die probleme dagegen
wird meistern ja zur dienstpflicht und
zwar aus vielerlei gründen kann denn die
jungen leute nicht für alle ja ich finde
er den begriff junge leute so schwierig
vor allem wenn er von älteren kommt aber
nasenbluten jetzt auch schon 29 werde im
august reiche ihr lachen aber nach dem
abi
finden sie denn nicht hergab freuen wenn
sie sagen die jugend fordern oder da
muss ich sagen was ich für die jugend
erlebt habe in der korona pandemie die
leidensfähigkeit für alte menschen haben
die sich zurückgenommen obwohl er wissen
sie also wissen sie ich bin sehr dafür
sozusagen
verärgert wenn sie so ein wort bemühen
die leidensfähigkeit wo fängt denn bei
ihnen leiden an dass man nicht in die
disco gehen kann gelesen oder wo ja aber
sie konnten in die schule gehen und sie
waren nicht ja gut ich bin gegen die
maßnahmen gewesen ich persönlich aber
gleichwohl ein doch nicht von leiden
weil wenn wir ein bisschen
ausgangssperre sp werden angeblich hier
ein großer virus herum läuft ich bin der
auffassung leiden dieses ganz was
anderes wir haben eine verzerrte die
junge generation die mit einer
erwartungshaltung durch die kante läuft
dass einem übel wird mit dieser
generation wie sie heute ist hätten wir
den nachkriegszeit nicht bestanden sie
auch dass die korona maßnahmen da nicht
leidend war für die jungen leute
selbstverständlich waren die leiden also
ich glaube wir doch jetzt hier mal also
wirklich butter bei die fische also was
ist es denn gewesen wenn ich heute 18
bin oder 17 bin mein abitur gerade macht
wir denken an den ersten kuss die erste
reise ohne eltern die abifeier die abi
fahrt natürlich sind das prägende dinge
die hatten wir alle die sind alle wegen
der pandemie ausgefallen ich habe viele
der maßnahmen auch für völlig überzogen
gehalten aber noch mal ganz kurz dazu
also ich glaube wir haben momentan eine
generation dieses hoch politisch hoch
engagiert das mag uns auch nicht immer
passen das sage ich dazu aber sie gehen
auf die straße sie engagieren zum
beispiel aber auch so wenn man im
politischen gespräch ist die kollegin
wird sicherlich auch bestätigen können
man kriegt viele anfragen von jungen
menschen und wir dürfen eines nicht
vergessen die erziehungsaufgabe haben
die eltern und nicht der staat jetzt
zusagen über eine dienstpflicht sollen
sie sozusagen
gerne insofern ordnung reinbringen als
wir hier eigentlich zwei themen
gegeneinander diskutieren die eigentlich
erst mal gar nichts miteinander zu tun
haben weil die dienstpflicht hat mit
corona gar nichts zu tun wir haben sie
haben wir haben nur gerade einen zeit
eine zeitliche korrelation und ich würde
ihnen ja zu stimmen dass ich habe auch
für kinder und die durch die korona zeit
gebracht und insofern weiß ich dass
kinder auf viel verzichtet haben auch
jugendliche ich habe auch einen sohn der
kein abi hatte ich mein ja wieso also an
die brust nur um diese generation
sondern es geht ja das grundsätzliche um
die frage irgendwie verlangen wir von
der jungen generation die im übrigen
immer früher aus der schule geht und
noch nicht mehr lebensfähig ist also die
ist noch nicht mein sohn wird mit der
nächste wird mit 17 abitur haben der ist
noch nicht bereit das er eigentlich in
die welt entlassen wird die frage ist
also verlangen können wir als
gesellschaft verlangen und zwar würde
ich das durchaus auch mit lohn bezahlen
also das heißt ja ich will ja nicht
irgendwie sklavenarbeiter oder irgendwie
sozusagen außen sollten sie denn geben
ich würde eher sagen wir mal nicht unter
5 600 euro im monat für dich also ich
finde nicht dass es ja auch alles genau
das stört nicht das ist das einzige was
mich stört an der forderung im moment
dass es auch sozusagen wieder mit dem
pflegenotstand mit allem möglichen zu
agieren
ja aber in der ganzen welt in der regel
kriegen die vielleicht 150 euro davon
können sie auch als als junger
menschliche leben also wenn dann sollte
das durchaus finde ich vernünftig
vergütet werden aber dass wir sagen als
gesellschaft jeder gibt auch etwas in
die gesellschaft hinein und ich glaube
dass es für den charakter bildung von
jungen menschen durchaus eine gute sache
ist wenn sie mal ein jahr etwas tun was
sie sich vielleicht gar nicht so sehr
aus suchen aber ich glaube dass sie das
dass das durchaus einen positiven effekt
hat aber ich wäre bei ihm dass man keine
ausbeutung betreiben sollen nach dem
motto wunderbar wir verpflichten jetzt
die jungen menschen weil wir haben
pflegenotstand wir brauchen alice oder
sonstwer freiwillige soziale jahr naja
ich habe ihn schon für eine
verpflichtung aber für eine die ja nicht
zwingend nicht vergütet werden muss da
würde ich ein und 26 euro würden reichen
würden sie sagen ja das
sollten sie auch in der mensch immer
auch eine debatte ist ja typisch für
unser land ist wird sie erst gefragt
wenn ich etwas geben soll was gibt mir
der stadt zurück und dann ist
materielles ich finde das alter grund
war der grundkrankheiten unseres landes
seiner familie sie sagen die familie
muss ihn ja heute ist die berufstätige
frau das ideal und der berufstätige mann
wurden da die familie wo ist denn die
zeit sich um kinder zu kümmern es ist
übergegangen jetzt sagen wir wussten
fragen sie nicht meine kinder kümmern
können die tageslicht in dem maße wie
frauen die nicht berufstätig sind und
die fest überzeugt
also ich kenne viele frauen die
berufstätig sind und ist gut und da ja
ich gerne auch andere vereine freuen das
ist vielleicht auch eine generation habe
ich da hat wohl nur frau laura treiben
und sie dafür sind sie dagegen dass
junge leute verpflichten das ist ja der
punkt der forderung dass freiwillige
gibt es ja schon das dienst ja ab wir
absolvieren sollen für die gemeinschaft
sich in den dienst der gemeinschaft
schaffe ich bin ehrlich bin hin und
hergerissen weil also zum einen sehe ich
ursprünglich verfassungsrechtliche
problematik die trotzdem nicht ohne ist
wir haben ja die wehrpflicht ausgesetzt
das ist so nach der verfassung darf man
ja eigentlich keinen arbeitszwang
einführen die ausnahme war die
wehrpflicht um quasi als
befreiungsbescheid dann der sozialen
dienst
allerdings sehe ich auch den vorteil ich
kann nur sagen mein schwager hat damals
sich entschieden in dem altenheim zu
arbeiten oder mobilen pflegedienst der
hat gesagt ich habe sachen gelernt die
hätte ich so nie gesehen und der
profitiert heute noch davon ich war
betreuungs richterin ich bin da
beruflich reingeschmissen worden ich
hätte mir das so nicht rausgesucht
dadurch lernst du eine andere sicht auf
die dinge ist und ich glaube das
freiwillige sozialjahr machen sie es
nicht die die die es machen das ist ja
jetzt die machen ja aber wahrscheinlich
schon eine eine soziale ader die haben
schon dieses bewusstsein dass sie auch
für die gesellschaft etwas tun wollen
sehr viele haben dass in den jungen
jahren nicht ob es natürlich schwierig
wir wissen's fdp die leute fehlen als
arbeitskraft das ist natürlich argument
ich sehe auch ihr problematik dass man
sagt wirklich die haben echt jetzt auch
zurück gesteckt das ist ja jetzt will
man dass junge menschen die nicht die
ausbildung haben loslassen in die
sozialen berufe das ist ja oder manga
auch die anforderung wurde ja die
anforderung und was ich noch fragen
möchte frau lang hatte ich kann das
heute ganz spannend ist nicht mein
gedanke ich würde es gerne das sagen
aber es habe ich heute der zeit gelesen
er hat eine autorin gefordert lasst doch
die alten ran also dass jeder gast dann
macht war aber die eltern kümmern sich
doch jetzt schon um die noch älteren
also jetzt mal ganz ehrlich wer pflegt
denn die meisten wenn zu hause gepflegt
zwei drittel pflegen zu hause und er
macht das denn das machen jetzt machen
deutschland
aber weil die frau die mit sich erzählt
die eh schon angeschlagen sind die
pflegen auch noch ihre mutter und ihre
schwiegermutter
die älteren die älteren herren mit
verlaub die hatten alle noch die
wehrpflicht und haben gedient die haben
eigentlich ihr sommer mal ihr mann
erst ab 70 sofortige
aussetzung bis 70 denn die längere
lebenserwartung die nachweisbar ist
belegbar ist ein zeichen dafür dass auch
gesundheit und fähigkeiten in diesem
also durchaus noch vorhanden sind da
würden wir nämlich unser rentensystem
ein bisschen ins gewicht regen wir sind
eine wohlfühl und zettel kultur in
diesem land die wir auch jetzt für die
jungen generationen schon wieder kuschen
mein gott ich bin ganz anderer meinung
als die frau keller wir haben einen
pflegenotstand der hat auch gründe aber
dann müssen eben in der gesellschaft die
ressourcen mobilisiert werden eine
gesellschaft besteht nicht
wohin ich sagte maus nicht nein ich will
und wenn du hier finde dass sie nicht
das recht haben also dass wir auch als
gesellschaft nicht das recht haben
jugendliche sozusagen finanziell
auszubeuten in dem wir sagen wir
verpflichten sie sozusagen und geben
ihnen gar kein ausgleich weil wir würden
ja gleichzeitig parallel im übrigen
erwarten dass die eltern gleichzeitig
diese kinder auch noch ernähren also ich
nehme einfach meine ich hab zwar nicht
weshalb sich das heißt wenn sie meine
beiden kinder verpflichten und denen nur
ein taschengeld geben dann nicht nur
leisten meine kinder dann noch ein
ganzes jahr eine dienstpflicht sondern
ich unterhalte diese kinder auch noch
dafür das heißt auch sie nehmen auch
mischen die pflicht aber das schulde bin
ich der meinung dass es eine
kompensation finanziell geben muss ich
aber bei ihnen für die dienstpflicht
weil ich glaube das habe ich
halt auch nicht hört man im moment
passiert also müsste doch und sie müssen
uns erst mal die realität anschaffen die
dienstpflicht macht allein deswegen
schon gar keinen sinn in der diskussion
weil die anforderungsprofile ganz anders
sind jetzt zu sagen die schicke ich alle
in die pflege pflege hat sich doch in
den letzten 20 30 jahren auch entwickelt
es wird viel digitaler wir reden im
pflege ausschuss ihre über pflege
akademisierung und nicht mehr über den
normalen pflegehelfer das gleiche habe
ich meinem navi glauben ich gesagt ja
das hat sich verändert glaubt man klären
durch den hammer wir haben auch beim
thema kunden kurze das selbst generell
mittlerweile generell überzeugung sind
dass eine wehrpflicht kann sinn macht
das technische gerätes hatte höhere
anforderungen ich brauche mir
schulungseinheiten wenn ich die für
zwölf monate habe dann kostet mich das
ausbildung dann kostet mich das
investition aber ich habe im endeffekt
das organisation kann nutzen wenn sie
mir jetzt ein gegenmodell aufmachen wo
wir unterbringen könnten dann können wir
vielleicht sogar noch mal drüber reden
aber dies gibt es nicht das ist reine
weil das land also in unserem hotel ab
sondern wir haben nämlich ihre these
mitgebracht zu wo zum krieg zu russland
und das ist ja auch nicht nein
nein das macht nichts das ist nicht
wichtig es geht hier nur darum das
natürlich ein aspekt bisher gar nicht
erwähnt wurde es geht auch darum dass
alle in der gesellschaft mal irgendwann
während ihres lebens zusammen und das
war die bundeswehr das war dann der
arbeitersohn der sohn des hilfsarbeiters
und der sohn von mir aus auch fußball
von mir oder sowas sonst was aber auch
der akademie gration der unternehmersohn
wir werden mal welten alles super
funktioniert mit der geräte ja ja das
ist rekord sind die geschichten von
gestern reden über heute und die
gesellschaft hat heute aber viele können
da nicht hin weil das geld kostet
variierte versuchen sondern hierfür ihre
kind hier irgendwas stadt berlin
aufnahme in einen sportverein zu kriegen
da gibt's diese frage wurde so hart wird
und so weiter aber dass er den regen her
und an kleinigkeiten herum der punkt ist
dieser gesellschaft hat
jetzt putin
sie haben ja gesagt na ja also als ich
heute morgen hörte dass 40 prozent davon
hatte ich mich richtig gefreut okay weil
die deutschen müssen langsam an aus dem
dornröschenschlaf wir machen den den
schönen menschen der welt der rest so
aus die amerikaner die drecksarbeit in
der verteidigung in der sicherheit und
in all diesen bereichen
sie müssen langsam mal wach werden dass
die realität nicht darin besteht dass
der zucker im lokal des konsums und des
wohl lebens so schön so der polizei
zeigt sein gesicht ganz klar übrigens
sind wir nicht das erste land bulgarien
in den baltischen staaten hatte er auch
runtergefahren haben die anderes
vorgesorgt aus meiner sicht sieht wird
er sagen sie mir die versorgung ist
gesichert sie ist jetzt gesichert wir
haben in diesem zeitpunkt in diesem
moment die geringsten gasdruck auch den
im jahresverlauf wir haben also eine
high life situation lassen sie erst mal
kommen die haben sich vorbereiten dass
sie können dass die reserven die
übrigens auch unter kontrolle russische
unternehmen liegen die wir jetzt mit
weiterfinanzieren mit mirja und vielen
milliarden die gasspeicher das bündnis
90 prozent gefüllt sein werden das sind
wir davon ausgegangen dass angela die
mir
war mir erinnerung hatte laune hat und
seine freundin angela weiterhin dieses
wunderbaren den stoff aus dem die träume
sind lieber tut er aber nicht und dann
wird es ein bisschen kalt werden und ich
garantiere ihnen werden die atomkraft
mit handkuss wieder begrüßen und wir
werden die kohlekraftwerke weise haben
weil sie vernünftig sind und wir werden
auch die gaskraftwerke weile haben die
vernünftig sind und wir werden deswegen
nicht frieren weil in der hoffentlich in
der politik und setzt sich sehr auf ihre
partei dass die in diesen tagen die fdp
ist offen
ende jänner die wende rückwärts bei
maria angela ja das ist meine hoffnung
und deswegen danke ich mich dass uns die
russen zeigen wo hier ahnt handels den
most holt aber der ist die regierung
jetzt die völlig falsche dafür glaube
ich für
wie viel rückhalt sowieso naja ich ja
also ich glaube halt nicht dass sie alle
ihren positionen verraten also enorm das
faktische straßendemonstrationen werden
die ware das hat möglicherweise eben gar
nicht politisch ist sozusagen in dem
parlament fliegen sondern das werden wir
deutschen krieg wenn sie das erste mal
ihre rechnungen nicht mehr bezahlen wenn
es wenn es stromausfall ist wenn wir den
ersten blick auf mal haben weil unsere
ganze energie versorgung zusammenbricht
dann bin ich sehr gespannt wie viele
leute immer noch auf die atomkraft
verzichten wollen oder ob wir dann
endlich mal darüber reden dass
deutschland mal in die lage versetzt
wird sich alleine energiepolitisch
überhaupt zu ernähren wird ja wir sind
ja wir haben ja das glück dass wir
sozusagen gemeinten noch freundliche
nachbarn haben wir sind von freundlichen
nachbarn umgeben uns freundlicherweise
diese energie auch den strom liefern den
wir selber nicht mehr produzieren weil
wir ja sagen wir machen atomfreie und
wenn die russen nehmen braucht noch den
harz drehen und dann wird es dann
wirklich sehr ungemütlich werden und
spätestens im herbst wenn die
energiewende auch der energiebedarf
steigen wird und dann wird das gar nicht
der die fdp brauchen weil dann wenn die
leute auf der straße nämlich sehr
unruhig werden und dann wird der druck
auch auf eine rot-grüne regierung
deutlich größer werden weil dann kann
herr habe ich uns erklären warum wir
frieren sollen die hörer gilt doch schon
die erwartet ja die fdp braucht das was
ich erst für seine fdp brachte ist das
immer aber was sich an der these ganz
spannend finde wir müssen ja was
politisches davon auch ableiten und ich
glaube das muss uns mal zu der
diskussion führen wir haben es mit
russland erlebt wie verhalten wir uns
zum beispiel auch gegenüber der
volksrepublik china geben wir uns da
wieder in wirtschaftliche abhängigkeiten
machen wir das gleiche modell das wir
jetzt sozusagen auch mit den russen ja
jetzt auch gerade vorgeladen bekommen
durch andere herrscher ich glaube dass
wir auf alle fälle lernen müssen dass
wir für unsere werte robust auch im
zweifel einstellen und das ist glaube
ich eine position als ein hartes warum
genau es geht darum dass wir nicht
erpressbar sind und deswegen ist zb mein
blick schon eher richtung china also wir
werden aus russland jetzt in richtung
volksrepublik müssen und da muss auch
europa zusammen stehen also warum
erkennen wir zum beispiel nicht endlich
die republik taiwan an sagen das ist ein
verbündeter für uns im asiatischen raum
und arbeiten dann sozusagen auch daran
wie wir uns wirtschaftlich unabhängig
von china machen können das machen ja
nicht mal die amerikaner naja lassen sie
uns doch mal mutig sein körper den tag
was ich dann noch viele kröten
wahnsinnige projekte zur zeit lang ein
totalitäres system ist gar keine frage
und wie russland auch ganz klar und wir
haben uns abgewöhnt zwischen freiheit
und unfreiheit zu unterscheiden wird
döbeln völlig prinzipienlos von sind nur
jedes wissen nur mit arroganz und
überheblichkeit
ich kann ihnen sagen es wird ganz bitter
werden aber ich sitze auf die normative
kraft des faktischen und was ich
vermisse ist eine wirkliche ehrliche
diskussion die wird nicht kommen der ära
merkel es tut mir leid es sind hier am
tisch vertreter der unionsparteien sie
die fdp ich bin noch stille leiden
die erwarte er
für dieses land eine heimsuchung und
zwar in mehreren
mehreren kapiteln die fragen der einmal
verloren ist davon erzählt wie sie
erwischen das interview von frau merkel
gesehen wo sie jetzt ist alles meine
stimme geben hat gehört haben ist fanden
sie sie da selbstkritisch haben sie als
selbst kritische blicke brawn kanzlerin
wahrgenommen oder glauben sie dass die
union schon auch in sich drin jetzt
hadert mit der zurückliegenden
energiewende
selbstkritisch so richtig habe ich sie
nicht lebt weil sie ja doch auch so ein
bisschen versucht hat so erklären
bisschen mehr wie sonst auch glaube ich
getan hat
ja es ist also im verhältnis zu putin
also ich sage mal ganz ich habe sowieso
meine eigene these wenn ich ganz ehrlich
bin ist irritiert aber es ist sicher
nicht allgemeiner union sprechen dann
gestohlen ich persönlich glaube ich sage
ich ihnen ganz ehrlich dass sie putin
mit nord stream zwei den den krieg
abgekauft hat sozusagen dass sie ihn
richtig eingeschätzt hat politisch
meiner man sie die anders sind zwei klug
war nein nein nein aber sie hat ihn
sozusagen ruhig gehalten um in weltkrieg
schon früher zu verhindern indem sie in
das ist so typisch so habe ich die auch
erlebt probleme ab raum in dem man was
gibt ja das war doch
ein gefühl von mir so wie ich es
empfinden das ist nicht unions haltung
sagt auch keiner das ist nur so so wie
ich sie erlebt habe und viele probleme
ich sage mal energiewende also ich zb ma
konnte das machen das war und damals
umstritten ich war sogar so dass ich
dachte vielleicht ist es auch eine
chance weltweit mal wieder in einem
neuen bereich auch weltmarktführer zu
sein wenn wir die ersten sind also ich
habe da durchaus positiv gedacht aber
dann wurde halt groß entschieden das
politische thema abgeräumt und dann aber
nicht alle kraft darauf gesetzt und es
zu lösen ist auch das was ich am meisten
vorwürfe in ihrer regentschaft dass sie
wenn ich so eine mega entscheidung
treffe nicht mit von kraft mit den
besten leuten da reingeht dass ich das
thema dann auch wirklich in zehn
fünfzehn jahren gelöst habe das ist doch
dass wenn ich so ein mega projekt mache
wie
unabhängige erneuerbaren energien setze
und das ist das wo ich bei ihr mehrfach
erlebt habt thema abräumen schieben aber
wird schon hoffentlich gut gehen und und
so ist es ja also deshalb hab ich dieses
gefühl dass sie putin richtig
eingeschätzt hat hier sehr gute
menschenkenntnis
außenpolitisch unglaublich erfahren und
in still gehalten hat und gehofft hat
dass sich das vielleicht alleine in
havanna aber dann ist es doch von dieser
schule nur zwischen frage glauben sie
dass wenn frau merkel geblieben wäre als
kanzlerin der krieg nicht ausgebrochen
wäre
ich das kann ich auch nicht so sagen
also ich glaube er hat einen moment um
genutzt wo er dachte das ist der
optimale termin schwachen olaf scholz
wäre es jetzt da wir haben ok mit einem
aus seiner sicht vielleicht schwachen
jetzt falsch eingeschätzt das mediale
kompetenzen der heutigen welt starke
persönlichkeit und führer sein können
die er dachte diesen schwach er hat
gedacht jetzt ist regierungswechsel
nicht die die schon lange kennt und und
ihre netzwerke die hat ja natürlich
netzwerke weltweit hat dann aber wusste
ja dass die damit drohen jetzt alles
auszusteigen erneuerbare energien also
die neue ampel regierung am sehr groß
verkündet nord stream 2 und ich glaube
sagt komm jetzt zeige ich euch mal wie
abhängiger seite war da mal sehen wir
bei dir her kommt mit eurem
überheblichen wir schaffen das alles
klar sie löst sein konnte also das heißt
er hat aus seiner sicht meiner
einschätzung nach ich bin kein experte
ist perfekte moment für seinen plan es
ist nicht so aufgegangen wie er sich das
vorgestellt hat
er war doch selbst überrascht wie
überrascht dass die europäer glaube ich
alle so außerdem ein geheimnis
ich glaube dass ich glaube dass wir von
glück reden können dass wir im moment
nicht mehr von merkel regiert werden
weil dann hätten wir nämlich diese
einigkeit nicht und wir hätten wieder
abnehmen politik der ukraine gegenüber
wir hätten genau dieselbe situation wie
damals als als die krim annektiert wurde
und man ihn hat gewähren lassen es war
doch eine frau merkel mit ihrer
regierung die die die zugelassen hat
dass die russen sich die creme genommen
hätten und sie hätten jetzt genauso
reagiert und genau damit hat
würde ich sagen sie können von glück
reden dass wir gerade von der ampel
regiert werden weil natürlich auch
realpolitisch jetzt eine rot-grüne
regierung genau das machen würde was sie
bekämpfen würde wäre merkel und die cdu
man auch in der regierung dann hätten
wir nämlich die friedensbewegung auf der
straße und jetzt muss eine frau burgtor
unter reichen und muss den leuten
erklären warum wir nicht helfen das hält
man sie nicht weil sie realpolitisch
sieht es ist nötig und das war damals
schon die ruhe
dieselbe situation und wir können
wirklich von glück reden dass angela
merkel nicht mehr im amt aber das ist
doch auch die frage wie wir da endlich
mal außenpolitisch auch in den umgang
treten also wir haben es ja sowohl in
der europäische wenn ich mir anschaue
die diskussion zu polen die diskussion
zu ungarn die haltung erdogan also
brauchen eine gewisse robustheit und ein
gewisses ein eintreten draußen und ohne
die schaffen das nicht
[Gelächter]
angenehm sein
charme den sie auch schwangere frau ich
finde es abenteuerlich wie sie eine
bundeskanzlerin gehört sein dass sie in
die zukunft hinein mutmaßt dass herr
putin musste nur lesen was gegeben hat
vielleicht auf ihre gesten reagiert
sagen sie mal eine bundeskanzlerin muss
strategischen ausblick haben sie muss
alle dinge ganz klar beherrschen
dieser etat ich will das gar nicht
weiter ausführen dass für die bilder der
großen ärger bedeuten aber wie kann man
denn beim hausbau beginnen indem man das
dach zuerst macht und nicht das
fundament der liga und energie flach und
haben keine möglichkeiten von nord nach
süd den energie energie zu
transportieren wenn das nicht ein stück
aus dem tollhaus ist von einer frau die
glaubt physikerin zu sein was sie wohl
auch ist und sagt sie denn da sieht sie
das ist freilich groß ein wie nannte er
das bewerte ich
rede über der abschlüsse das ist ein
thema für sich
und das bedeutet natürlich ich bin sehr
klar meiner einschätzung glauben sie mir
das hat eine menge kenntnis was das
betrifft diesen bereich deutschland also
die frau hat ganz klar gehandelt und
musste sehen welche folgen diese politik
hat und dies muss die deutsche
geschichte in der forschung eines tages
aufklären heute macht man das nicht weil
die cdu/csu eine folgsame
gleichgeschaltete truppe ist ich wünsche
friedrich merz sich nicht gut kenne alle
kraft stück für stück die alte union
nicht mit mir nicht die modernität aber
wer die offene diskussion in eurem
junior zu stellen frau merkel und ich
merke aber
dass
sie gedacht und gefühlt hat und gesagt
hat 'jetzt toll und ich liebe ja schon
an frauen hat nämlich heute von der csu
ein frisches eigenes thema mitgebracht
er zäsur immunität
[Gelächter]
idealisieren frau merkel wie sie durch
regiert hat auch in der partei in
keinster weise also das kann man glauben
ja nachlesen dass ich einer der wenigen
die es auch laut kritisiert haben sie
haben sie diese ja und es ist
entschieden ab das kann sie nicht
verlieren in der csu direktmandat das
ist ja
aber
was ich sagen will ist es nur meine
einschätzung wie es mir erklären kann
denn das ist nicht immer steht das
glaube ich nicht und dass sie eine
falsche menschenkenntnis bei putin hatte
das glaube ich auch nicht also ist es
angesagt
kein allgemeine meinung
das ist mir auch wirklich sorgen macht
sage ich ihnen ganz ehrlich und so
langsam kommt zwar hoch wir haben ich
habe das gefühl dass die ampel im moment
noch nicht so richtig meint lindner
betont ja dann sehen wir als nächstes
jetzt macht noch nicht richtig
verstanden hat dass man langfristig den
menschen wirklich keinen gefallen tut
wenn man immer neue schulden macht also
wir haben zwei jahre war jetzt wirklich
corona pandemie bedingt
ausserordentliche ausgaben und dadurch
auch wirklich zweimal ich sage mal ganz
groben über 200 milliarden schulden bei
rund 300 mehr nein haben also dass man
mega eigentlich im zweiten jahr noch
mehr aber er hat ja die 60 milliarden im
zweiten nachtragshaushalt rheingau ja
eigentlich ins nichts mehr gehören dann
sozusagen also dass man auf ähnliche
situation und im nächsten jetzt muss man
einfach sagen da habe ich eigentlich
gehofft dass man jetzt ein bisschen er
zumindest nicht mehr so extrem viele
schulden aufbauen wenn ich sogar mal
anfängt
abzutragen stattdessen haben wir jetzt
einen rekord an schulden jetzt verstehe
ich dass wir haben wieder eine neue
situation die ukraine krise man hat
gesehen da muss was machen militär man
hat gesehen was neue kosten im
zusammenhang mit flüchtlingen die
pandemie war noch nicht so schnell weg
machen neue herausforderung bei
kurzarbeitergeld und so weiter aber wenn
ich sehe die kosten laufen jetzt wieder
durch ein äußeres ereignis aus dem ruder
dann muss ich anfangen wirklich mal den
mut macht im dritten jahr haben und
sagen prioritäten setzen wenn das dass
das jetzt alles so wichtig ist auch die
entlastung der bürger wegen der
inflation das muss ich jetzt im moment
machen dann muss ich mal schauen wo kann
ich sparen das würde jeder normale
mensch musste es im moment machen bei
der inflation und jeder normale menschen
würde das auch machen und hier habe ich
in diesem haushalt zumindest bin ja
gespannt wie es jetzt im nächsten macht
aber in diesem haushalt kann ich sagen
absolut vermisst diese tendenz zu sparen
ganz im gegenteil es kommen neue ampel
projekte die sehr kostenintensiv sind
zum beispiel aussetzung der sanktionen
bei hartz 4 empfänger bei verstößen fast
alle halten sich daran die wissen dass
ich sozusagen auch mal
mitwirkungspflichten habe die ganz ganz
wenigen denen wenn das jetzt recht
machen die sich nicht daran halten und
das kostet wieder beträge und so geht's
ja eins nach dem anderen ich kann ihnen
sagen ich habe ja diesen etat ich konnte
dabei sind nicht glauben wir haben
vorschläge ohne ende gemacht auch im
detail nicht aufgegriffen worden ich
hatte das gefühl jetzt noch so viele
schulden wie möglich jetzt kommen wir da
noch einer schuldenbremse mitte mit dem
mit der ausrede pandemie noch so viel
wie möglich aufnehmen damit wird dann
beim nächsten mal muss jetzt anfangen zu
sparen aber das ist falsch ich muss
jetzt anfangen zu sparen die leute
merken testen hier direkt in
pcs und nicht nicht verstanden dass mit
der gottes willen die ja also was die
union auf alle fälle wo sie angekommen
ist nach der bundestagswahl ist in der
verantwortungslosigkeit ich glaube ich
sieht man auch an den außenkanten
bedeutungslosigkeit zurück es soweit ist
es noch nicht aber an der
verantwortungslosigkeit wenn ich mir
anschaue in welcher situation wir sind
wir haben mit dem krieg in der ukraine
wir haben mit der korona pandemie wo wir
im übrigen ja den haushalt und die
schulden ja er sozusagen gr haben wir
wissen ja auch nicht wie viele csu
leider noch in irgendwelchen masken mit
stark wie schuldenbremse geworben
absolut aber niemand wusste den 24
februar das ist ein argument und man
muss fairerweise sagen 100 milliarden
die wir jetzt zum beispiel das
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr
brauchen das ist ja eigentlich eine 100
milliarden die ich eigentlich der union
in rechnung stellen muss weil die hat 16
jahre alt und es war sagen nach vermögen
es ist nicht eigentlich eine lüge am
bürger sondervermögen sind sie einfach
schön
ja ich muss gestehen ich würde ich jetzt
da keine etiketten
bevorteilung markiert sind die faktor
auch schulden ich würde es als
sondervermögen bezeichnen weil das das
offizielle wording sozusagen ist und
weil ja aber fakt ist ja wir haben 100
milliarden euro die wir investieren
mussten bei 16 jahre lang die bundesliga
start wir haben wir haben ich weiß gar
nicht haben sie das schon mal in an die
chance ausgerechnet wie viele hundert
milliarden in an die
spitze der opposition geräte also ich
kann ihnen nur sagen wir haben die ganze
zeit da die opposition zum sieger ja ja
aber sie haben leider noch nicht kapiert
es ihres regieren und darüber ihn
verantwortlich
gemacht wenn man regiert das ist er
erlebe ich im ganzen doch mal gesehen
und da bringt man die opposition zu
bestimmen wo ich mir denke noch nicht in
tritt gekommen wir sind ja und da dürfen
wir jetzt schon einmal
was ich sagen will also wirklich die
verteidigungspolitischen ausgaben es ist
nicht so dass die fdp da so großzügig
war in der zeit wo wir gemeinsam regiert
haben die spd hat auch immer gebremst
also dass die union jetzt ist die mit
aller macht immer das militär ruinieren
wollte also das glaube ich dass können
sie niemandem
wenn wir mehr wollten mussten uns dafür
verteidigen weil sie einfach kann man ja
zugeben die meisten menschen im land
haben auch gedacht das braucht ist wenn
es in japan die haben ihre
schiedsrichter ich würde jetzt mal frau
kelle fragen als bürgerin fühlen sie
sich gut als die union das geld
verwaltet hat jetzt wo die fdp ist und
wann haben sie sich der mann nun auf gut
aufgehoben gefühlt als bürgerin mit
ihrem steuergeld in beim steuergeld habe
ich mich noch nie gut aus ich glaube das
ist auch eine partei und ein zumal man
ja sehen muss auch die cdu hat ja die
ganzen jahre auch in der großen
koalition mit der spd zusammen regiert
das hat ja durchaus auch einfluss gehabt
ich glaube dass wir einen anderen umgang
mit geld gehabt hätten tatsächlich in
einer schwarz gelben koalition aber
hatten wir ja nicht insofern ist glaube
ich der unterschied nicht so groß würde
mich anschließend eine kritik dass das
sagen nicht mehr erkennbar ist dass man
sparen wird in irgendeiner form und es
gebe ja durchaus eine menge eine menge
ansätze was mir viel mehr sorgen macht
ist diese sorglosigkeit mit der wir in
eine riesige inflation rennen in val
d'isere sparen dringend normaler
menschen einfach weg sind wo ich sage da
hat da sitzt der normale kleine bürger
sitzt da und verliert gerade alles was
er hat und viele bürger haben ja in der
korona panini ja auch eine ganze menge
an ihren reserven schon aufgebraucht das
heißt es ist viel erspartes ausgegeben
worden weil man die person wie sonst
nicht überlebt hätte und jetzt kommt
diese galoppieren der inflation dazu
jetzt kommen die steigenden
energiepreise dazu und unsere regierung
macht überhaupt nichts so und da finde
ich schon da da müsste eigentlich viel
mehr kommen und mit den energiepreisen
würde ich anfangs ja also meine meinung
dazu wissen wir leben immer noch so als
sei das ganze leben ein wunschkonzert
denn
schulden haben sie alle gemacht immer
mehr und immer mehr und es gibt genügend
menschen bund der steuerzahler und
andere die aufzeigen wo wir sparen
könnten es gibt unmengen an aufwendungen
im gesamten ideologischen bereich denken
sie nur an die gender professuren die
eingerichtet werden ich frage mich was
die forschen keiner und lief
davon wegen 250 professorenstellen und
die weinland also dann werden vor allen
dingen die abgeschlagene janina
beauftragte geschaffen diese regierung
alleine im bereich der staatssekretäre
und anderer in diesem durch staatlichen
bereich zu verbeamten de und hoch zu
holen de und kohle zu geben massiv
aufgegangen ist und das ist eine frage
der frau dann fühle ich mich als
steuerzahler und ich zahle über 50
prozent steuern insgesamt fühle ich mich
einfach dazu am als schwein als
besserverdienender fühle ich nicht
natürlich für rechtlich war hab ich kann
auch im gehalt verraten
haben sie haben doch frühen geredet von
ganz klar von der freiheit noch hören
sie mal zu helfen sie mir mal
[Gelächter]
nein aber ich bin der meinung dass ihnen
eine eine vielseitige logisch
überfrachteter dinge
sonderbeauftragte für alles mögliche die
unternehmen werden mit der schule regelt
bis in ihre verantwortung wie viele
frauen sie in der führung haben dass sie
mal was ist denn das für ein land wir
bewegen uns doch hier weg in ein
tollhaus der haben einige auftraten
vereinigten dass sie haben nein es gibt
tausend dingen das ist nicht nur dass
auch diese schlampereien der verwaltung
und die verwaltung allein in berlin wenn
sie sich das bauwesen ansehen es dauert
zehn jahre vom stern eines antrags auf
eine baugenehmigung bedingung zehn jahre
da wissen sie da hat er gesagt bei denen
diesen leuten wir hatten wir für möbel
und johann den trümmern setzen von 45
sowie sich nur vor was aus diesem land
geworden ist eine aufgebrachte
monsterbürokratie die brauchen sie aber
weil das wähler sind es sind schichten
die werden alimentiert weil die parteien
gewisse parteien die auch als wfp
brauchen und das geht auf kosten der
[Gelächter]
diffamieren damit frauen die sich so
viel entscheiden hause zu bleiben und
ihre kinder zu hören sie sollten sich
schämen sie sollten sie schützen darüber
sollte ja so dass sie doch vielleicht
ist
das heißt die linke propaganda der krise
konkret verhalten
progressiver märz drehen ist wegen des
untergangs
[Musik]
also da kann ich dann ein lauter
brauchen nicht ernst nehmen als
sogenannten experten
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren bei 14 85 köpfen sind meinungen
jeder von uns hat ein thema mitgebracht
was ihn bewegt ärgert freut oder
schockiert
so nicht retuschiert
auge ist aber niemand von den
politischen parteien traut sich zu sagen
ja das wollen wir einfach nur freiheit
diese grün-roten der damen führen
hochtrabende debatten über die rettung
des weltklimas und um die füße russland
die ratten das thema ist viel zu wichtig
um es nur derart dazu übergangen lasst
den leuten soll man den spaß wir sehen
da etwas was eigentlich vertrag ist in
der politik bei den journalisten deren
job ist es doch gerade abweichende
meinungen zu finden und sie sollen den
doch auch richtig durch das tragen eines
party zum manko vielleicht einmal kurz
einsatz erinnert werden wir ganz nennen
doch das sind übliche anorak träger aus
in bewegung bringen ich hatte meinen
beifall über eine sache immer bekommt er
kümmert sich darum niemand das ist was
zählt ist er ganz klar ist eigentlich
auch darüber sprechen das ist ein fakt
nicht fertig richtig wohl ist die
aufgabe von journalismus einfach die
verlautbarungen der politik zu
hinterfragen
[Musik]
wir sind zurück aus einer kurzen pause
die hier sehr redselig war ich hoffe bei
ihm zu hause auch und jetzt machen wir
direkt weiter mit frau kelle und ihren
wichtigen thema heute haben ich würde
gerne über italien sprechen in italien
haben wir jetzt plötzlich eine übermacht
von jungen afrikanern und jungen männern
aus den maghreb staaten die den gardasee
erobert haben und es auch genau so
nennen vergangenen donnerstag gaben
haben 2000 junge männer eine badeort
gestürmt haben frauen belästigt haben
randaliert und wir sind in deutschland
nicht vorbereitet auf so etwas wir
können eigentlich nur von glück reden
dass es uns in den letzten jahren nicht
so erwischt hat aber der gardasee hat
jetzt seine eigene kölner domplatte und
genaugenommen diskutiert jetzt italien
das integrationsproblem dass wir in
deutschland auch haben und was wir jetzt
seit vielen jahren konsequent vor uns
herschieben und es würde mich nicht
wundern wenn wir das im sommer als
problem auch bekommen jedes mal wenn so
ein ereignis ist schweigen in
deutschland die meisten medien man hat
hier gar nicht viel mitbekommen weil es
die falschen täter sind wir diskutieren
lieber über gender sterne und über die
schuld des alten weißen mann ist wir
bekommen in europa aber gerade ein
problem mit dem jungen schwarzen und ich
würde gerne darüber reden ohne dass man
sofort immer mit der keule kommt das sei
rechts dass die islamophobie oder sonst
was wir haben letztes wochenende auch in
düsseldorf wir haben in stuttgart wir
haben junge männer bannten genau mit
demselben profil die durch die stadt
laufen die allah akbar rufen dass es
kein freundschaftlicher gruß und ich
denke deutschland ist jetzt so weit dass
wir endlich eine integrationsdebatte
führen und zwar in einem tenor die
bedeutet dass integration eine
bringschuld ist und nicht etwas was wir
als deutsche leisten frau keller ich
würde hier direkt ein haken vergessen
sie bei dem plädoyer nicht dass jeden
zweiten oder dritten tag wird eine frau
von ihrem partner getötet als wenn wir
über gewalt an frauen und hassan frauen
reden dann können wir eigentlich nicht
sagen dass er importiert ist das
paradies ohne gewalt gab es nicht vor
den flüchtlingen weil sich hier noch
ergänzen möchte wenn wir nur über die
migrationswelle reden es ist dann nicht
eigentlich für die deutschen weißen
männer die frauen feine sind ganz toll
wenn wir die gar nicht wir werden wir
schieben ist alles auf die flüchtlinge
und sagen die importieren uns die gewalt
an frauen aber ist gewalt an frauen
nicht ein viel größeres thema als das
zum beispiel am gardasee ich würde gerne
differenzieren wollen wir jetzt genau
das machen womit die debatte jedes mal
erstickt wird indem man sagt ja aber der
deutsche mann ist doch auch gewalttätig
ja das mag sein aber ich kann ihnen
sagen schon damals nach der kölner
domplatte um die als man tage braucht
über aber um überhaupt zur kenntnis zu
nehmen was da passiert ist bis heute
halt hält sich der mythos nach dem motto
das kennen wir doch das würde auch immer
auf dem oktoberfest stand finden und so
weiter ich kann ihnen sagen in ganz
europa hat es so etwas nicht gegeben
dass tausende tausende wir sprechen hier
nicht davon von von häuslicher gewalt
die gibt es wahrscheinlich leider
weltweit aber sondern dass im
öffentlichen raum junge männer die ganz
offensichtlich nichts zu tun haben
randalieren frauen begrapschen frauen
vergewaltigen soso einer hand heraus an
gewalt an frauen ist gucken sie sich die
die die polizeistatistik an ich würde er
einfach gerne differenzieren die
verschiedenen straftaten die
neutrassierung der anzahl wichtig wie
viel prozent sind das die
migrationshintergrund an dass die gewalt
an frauen wenn sie sagen dass mit dem
portier gewalt auf der straße ist glaube
ich irgendwie irgendwo bei 70 prozent
kann man bestimmt sagen also auch die
ich habe nicht nein aber diese eine
solche ereignisse also das haben wir als
junge männer sich zusammenrotten um
gezielt zu randalieren um tatsächlich
und sie haben sich gesammelt unter einem
hashtag den ich sehr spannend finde
nämlich an afrika in pescara und
demnächst irgendwie afrika sonst was das
heißt die haben ganz gezielt gebrüllt
auch slogans das ist polizei
dokumentiert in italien weiße frauen
haben hier nichts zu suchen das
skandierten diese jungen männer am
gardasee und entschuldigen sie so etwas
kenne ich ehrlich gesagt nicht von
europäischen jungen zum thema statistik
ja es ist sagen wir da wird auch nicht
ordentlich registriert was wann wie
passiert die polizei ist ja auch schon
an die correctness gebunden sonst kommt
sie ja sofort unter das profil das wie
nennt man das soziales israelische
profiling sie nicht dass vor allem wenn
er mit medaillen und mal gewalt
berichtet wird mir weil sie auf jeden
fall
jetzt kann ich meinen sie
das bundeskriminalamt man können sie den
chef des bundes getragen haben alle drei
mal in der woche finden in der
bundesrepublik gruppenvergewaltigung
statt diese gruppen vergewaltigung
schließlich auch manche stellen sie
schrecken ist wer öffentlich auf dem
deutschen bundestag sind von
flüchtlingen die
ausländischen
willkommenskultur gemäss als
geschmacklicher
keinen fall so sagt das weiß ich genau
wie sich für mich war das also dreimal
in der woche finden straftaten in einer
dimension stadt die gab es früher auch
aber nicht in diesem ausmaß und dazu
möchte ich was sagen wir dann erstaunt
wird erstaunen wird wissen sie wir holen
uns eine kultur ins land und sagen wir
wollen ja nicht mal mehr integrieren
denn wir folgen er den ansatz die welt
ist eine welt für alle menschen und die
menschen die eben integration wollen
heißt wiederkäuer kolonialismus nein
jeder soll sich so hier fühlen wie er
sich zu hause bei sich fühlt und da
müssen wir auch diese kultur nicht
achten und wenn ich ihnen sage in den
staaten aus denen die kommen passiert so
was ist also alles dinge sind
vergewaltiger oder wie wir uns jetzt aus
deutet so überdeutlich was ich jetzt
sagen
wir legen schon die straftaten begehen
reichen mir schon es müssen nicht alle
seien bereits schon dieser ausschnitt
und das ist also die folge auch dass wir
kein verständnis für deren kultur
aufbringen verstehen sie wenn bei uns
die frauen die fleischbeschau
am haken halb nackt durch die straßen
gehen im sommer dann stoßen wir auf ein
verständnis bei denen das sie freiwild
sind die frauen dort sind verhüllt das
mag ich nicht mag man nicht mögen ich
finde zum beispiel erotisch burka wenn
diese erotisch aber andere gesetze sie
immer wieder so ein super sexy dress ja
er muss halt etwas zu entdecken so und
du sollst mir also jede meinung aber sie
finden die burka sind die burg heißt
nicht dass kopf hat die mutter ist die
erste folge würden auch dieses thema zu
ernst
wir reden hier immerhin über straftat
gegen frau ich viele male in staaten des
nahen ostens und habe mich mit leuten
dort unterhalten männern und frauen
nicht alle frauen empfinden das als
unterdrückung und das aber ganz klar zu
sagen wir maßen uns an mit unseren
kulturbegriff durch die gegend zu ziehen
und anderen vorzuschreiben wie sie sich
zu kleiden
es geht um die frage was in europa sich
doch mal dass wir ruhig zu ende sicher
in ihrem sinne wir haben die polizei
greift nicht ein in köln hat sie nicht
eingegriffen in berlin haben die ich
kenne genug polizisten haben die angst
das ist seminar verfahren kriegen wenn
sie zugreifen weil natürlichen
beobachtet die polizei sind irgendwelche
grün und welche anderen männer dieser
rumrennen und die polizei beobachten ist
in ländern wo anders durchgegriffen wird
ist natürlich bei sich zu hause machen
die das nicht punkt zwei ist natürlich
werden sie nämlich bestraft bei sich zu
hause sehe das machen wir sehr hart es
gab zum beispiel interview
gruppenvergewaltigung also den schon
jetzt
ja sagen oder was ich gerade gesagt in
indien ich hatte ganz
schön ist oder um vergewaltigungen war
ja gesagt wurde in den heimatländern
machen sie es nicht nur sie machen also
in rabenstein und haben sich dann aber
wir haben es auch in pakistan aussage
das würde ich an zu schreiben die zeit
sage ja ok
ich hab' mir reden
bevor sie weiter hungrig und
leistungsfähige schien sich das damalige
das unternehmen hat uns immer auf
polemische um zu quatschen also lasst
uns
sagen nur noch kein einziger mann hat in
köln einmal frau geholfen das gibt es in
keinem anderen land auch nicht in
arabischen
dann sozusagen ihre männlichkeit müssen
sie sich schämen wenn sieben top
schützen ich glaube wirklich dass das
thema zu ernst ist und ich glaube ich
würde ja dieses thema nicht um
gerechtigkeit
da habe ich nicht gelassen aber
natürlich schon eine frage ist ist ich
habe mich dann jetzt da heute natürlich
auch mit dem fall eingelesen ich glaube
es ist die situation ja so dass es
überwiegend schon um die zweite
generation ging zumindest die festnahmen
ist glaube ich 30 leute sind ja
festgenommen worden wir legen zumindest
dass es schon zweiter generation ist
italienische staatsangehörige und das
ist doch eigentlich die frage die wir
haben wir müssen sozusagen und da gebe
ich sogar in gewisser weise recht
integration ist was wir einfordern
müssen und wir müssen auch in gewisser
weise konsequenter werden wenn zum
beispiel gegen strafrecht verstoßen
deswegen haben wir doch jetzt auch und
das glaube ich ist vor allem meine
partei auch ein korrektiv in der
bundesregierung zum beispiel die debatte
über den abschiebe beauftragten wir
wollen auch dahin gehen dass wir wieder
mehr abschieben wenn ich mir jetzt in
berlin anschauen wir haben ja hier das
unglück rot grün rot regiert zu werden
da passiert sowas einfach auch nicht
wenn ich natürlich keine konsequenzen
zeige auf straftaten auf fehlverhalten
dann brauche ich mich nicht wundern dass
ich es mache aber wir müssen in der
diskussion definitiv differenziert dass
sein wir müssen genauer hingucken nur
pauschal zu sagen es sind einwanderer
aus nordafrika stimmt halt nicht weil es
wie gesagt italienische staatsangehörige
was was diese über diese jungen männer
alle eint ist leider tatsächlich auch
einfach die herkunft auch aus einem
islamischen kulturkreis und wir wissen
wann ich meine ich wunder mich immer
darüber wie mit zweierlei maß gemessen
wird in der frage der frauenrechte in
der frage der übergriffe auf frauen man
muss ja nur einfach mal das
gedankenexperiment zu lassen stellen sie
sich mal vor irgendwie auch nur 100
deutsche männer würden irgendwie durch
die straßen ziehen oder würden in einem
zugwaggon über über fünf frauen
herfallen und sie vergewaltigen was in
diesem land los wäre ja oder auch auf
die kölner domplatte können sie sich
einfach mal in einer anderen kulturellen
situation vorstellen dass das nicht
männer mit migrationshintergrund gewesen
wären sondern deutsche männer was hätten
wir für eine debatte wir diskutieren
über jedes falsche wort eines deutschen
mannes aber hier haben wir einfach der
haben tatsächlich einfach eine
zuwanderung als einem kulturkreis die
die frau anders sieht so und dann müssen
wir endlich umgehen und das müssen wir
offen benennen weil wir sonst nämlich
gerade auch die zweite generation der
jungen männer nicht in den griff
bekommen das ist ja auch ein versagen
des elternhauses offensichtlich haben
die elternhäuser ja überhaupt kein
problem damit dass die das waren 16 17
jährige junge männer die da randalierend
auf den straßen sind wo sind da
eigentlich die eltern offensichtlich hat
wird das gutgeheissen und offensichtlich
wird das in die nächste generation so
weiter getragen das heißt dieses problem
wird vergrößert nicht verkleinert und in
dem man so tut als gäbe ist das problem
nicht oder indem man es klein redet oder
vergleich nach dem motto ja aber die
anderen haben auch straftaten ja aber
lasst uns doch bitte um beide lasst uns
um alle probleme kümmern ja und um die
probleme die der deutsche mann
verursacht gegenüber der frau aber
bitteschön gerade diese männer mit
zuwanderungsgeschichte mit einem
wirklich mittelalterlichen frauenbild um
die müssen wir uns kümmern und die
brauchen konsequenzen die brauchen
strafen so können sich nicht um ein kind
erziehen es gibt ja viele flüchtlinge
die auch in der pflege arbeiten und das
nächste thema hat herr bausteins
mitgebracht und das geht auch da ja wir
steuern auf einen pflegenotstand zu und
ich glaube was wir jetzt nicht mehr
brauchen ist das klassische politische
blabla sondern wir brauchen endlich
lösungen ich bin seit 20 jahren
politisch engagiert ich kenne das thema
pflege seit 20 jahren und wenn ich mir
die gesundheitsminister anschaut dann
unterhalten wir uns lieber über corona
maßnahmen vielleicht im winter 2025
gerade anstatt mal das problem und die
herausforderungen der pflege anzugehen
und wir steuern darauf mit voller
geschwindigkeit auf eine schlucht zu die
wir
sehenden auges anfahren und da müssen
wir umdenken allein die tatsache dass
wird bis 2035
500.000 pflegekräfte brauchen werden die
wir nicht haben und das ist ja jetzt
beginnt fast 20 millionen menschen gehen
jetzt an anfänglichen rente das wird
eine herausforderung und da brauchen wir
dringend lösungen und endlich handlung
also ich kann sagen dass man kann nicht
sagen dass dann nur blabla stattgefunden
hat und keine handlungen den letzten
jahren es ist wirklich ein paket nach
dem anderen aber sie haben recht es ist
immer zu wenig um ist immer hinterher
weil natürlich die bevölkerung älter
wird man braucht immer mehr pflegeplätze
die herausforderung weil immer größer
immer weniger machen es zu hause selbst
auch der anteil ist ja logisch die
frauen sind erwerbstätig die können zu
hause sich nicht mehr so um ihre eltern
oder großeltern kümmern das heißt das
problem spitzt sich immer mehr zu und
ich muss natürlich obwohl ja auch im
gehalt einiges gemacht haben ich bin
wirklich ich war ja auch betreuungs
richterin dadurch war ich ständig in
alten- und pflegeheim und bezirks
krankenhäusern seit dieser zeit ist das
auch ein thema das mich wirklich
unmittelbar beschäftigt ich habe
eigentlich als ich frisch im bundestag
bin wollte ich unbedingt ein riesenpaket
dann kam die flüchtlingswelle nach
riesenpaket jetzt dafür gebraucht das
ist in welcher situation sie in alten-
und pflegeheim gestoßen also es hat sich
inzwischen wirklich einiges verbessert
was aber definitiv der fall ist ist
dieses bürokratie was für für die
meisten pflegekräfte das schlimmste ist
sie sind auch jetzt wo sich gehaltsmäßig
ein bisschen was getan hat in den
letzten jahren viele die sagen das
gehalt ist das eine wir haben also
zumindest kann ich sagen in bayern im
ersten lehrjahr haben die 1000 euro das
ist gar nicht mal so schlecht wie man
kocht wie gesagt also im ersten lehrjahr
ist es nicht mal so schlecht
allerdings sagen eigentlich alle die
belastung schichtdienst viele wollen
deshalb auch als frauen wegen diesen
schichtdiensten nicht voll arbeiten
sondern nur teils seien die meisten
wollen nur viele wollen nur teilzeit
dann auch dieses nicht wertgeschätzt zu
werden das ansehen des berufes deshalb
ist vielleicht sozusagen diese diese
pflicht da mal reinzuschnuppern auch mal
überhaupt den bezug zu haben zu dieser
tätigkeit das ist für viele nicht schön
auch die abwertung ganz aktuellen wird
es jetzt auch als auch gebessert werden
aber trotzdem dass soviel immer noch
haben wir viele erzählt immer muss man
noch warten und der arzt muss extra
komme und was verschreiben aber wir
wissen genau was er braucht oder nicht
wir kümmern uns wir wissen was taugt
also da wäre es sinnvoll wirklich diese
tätigkeit insofern auch aufzuwerten ich
weiß dass man gleich die ärztelobby
dagegen dass das an sozusagen da mehr
gemacht wird es ist jetzt langsam im
gange aber da muss bringen weil das sind
eine wertvolle aufgabe und die muss auch
als so wertvoll angesehen werden da gibt
es die forderung nach den
gemeindeschwestern wo man sozusagen ein
bisschen
unverzichtbar ist für die gemeinde denn
ganz viele jobs werden gemacht wie
verdienen gar nicht mal so viel aber die
haben ein ansehen und die leute gehen da
drin auf und das ist so ein bisschen das
problem dass wir hier haben also
bürokratie fehlende wertschätzung und
vor allem auch arbeitszeiten aber auch
diese nicht selbst harry wind frau
keller einmal fragen kann ansehen die
miete zahlen ansehen zahlt die miete
nicht und ich sagen wir haben jetzt in
der korona zeit haben wir ja auch erlebt
dass es auch immer hieß nach dem motto
man müsse das aufwerten und so weiter
stattdessen hat man das ganze
pflegepersonal jetzt mit einer
impfpflicht noch zusätzlich gegängelt
und hat auch welche nach draußen
getrieben das muss man einfach auch so
sagen
ich würde allerdings auch vielleicht mal
einen aspekt in die politik hinein
bringen der völlig vergessen worden ist
sie sagen ja zu recht es braucht
sozusagen immer mehr pflege weil die
familie ausfällt ja weil immer mehr auch
frauen berufstätig sind was ihr gutes
recht ist gleichzeitig aber wenn wir
sagen wir kriegen werden wo wir wissen
ja nicht einmal wo wir die ganzen leute
her nehmen sollen für die pflege
gleichzeitig gibt es tatsächlich sehr
viele familien die würden gerne pflegen
würden sie das irgendwie kompensiert
bekommen warum nicht endlich die familie
stärken die meisten
die meisten ich kenne kaum einen alten
menschen der sagt ich will wenn ich alt
bin einträge heim das heißt alle
versuchen ja eigentlich eine lösung und
möglichst zu hause zu bleiben warum
können wir nicht deutlich mehr die
pflege zu hause fördern ich glaube dass
wir damit einen teil der lösung hätten
weil es sehr viele gibt die würden das
machen aber die sagen auch wir brauchen
die zwei gehälter wir wissen nicht wie
es machen sollen wenn aber eine familie
unterstützt wird weil sie die großeltern
pflegte oder die alten eigenen eltern
pflegt wenn es da eine kompensation geht
und das wäre wahrscheinlich deutlich
günstiger ist jeder pflegeplatz ein
normaler pflegeplatz kostet tausende von
euros und sie könnten wahrscheinlich für
die hälfte die pflege in die also mehr
geld die fahren 30.11.10 familie findet
in der familie statt wir haben 81
prozent in der pflege schon in den bei
der angehörigen also wir haben dann
großen teil was ich aber machen muss es
natürlich die pflegenden angehörigen zb
darüber zu reden ob ich denen die
sozialbeiträge zahlen weil das führt
später dann wieder zur altersarmut wenn
die keine rentenzahlungen und so
geschichte haben also ich glaube wir
müssen sowohl die also da ist halt alles
auf den oppositionellen teilen sagen
nichts gemacht da ist dann einstieg 200
er auch schon gemacht genau aber da ja
nein zu schließen wir machen ein
zustimmendes argument ich war vier jahre
in thailand fast vier jahre als leiter
der konrad-adenauer-stiftung und habe
dort vor meinem hinweggehen mit herrn
spahn ein langes gespräch geführt und
wir haben uns gemeinsam vorgenommen aus
teil 1 kräfte hierher zu holen ist es
mir gelungen weil es in seinem land eine
monarchie mit mit der diktatur nicht so
einfach ist hat bedeutende den
entscheidungsträgern vorzudringen das
hat ein briefverkehr stattgefunden wir
mein konzept entwickelt und da sparen
mussten wir dann sagen das ist in der
form wir haben auf zwei jahre angelegte
nicht durchsetzbar fünf jahre ist das
mindeste und muss ein konsens
hergestellt werden zwischen allen wir so
was im übrigen bevor wir das zeichen
gesetzt wissen sie bis dahin ist die
legislaturperiode nämlich um der
pragmatismus mit dem andere mit so etwas
umgehen ich musste mein gesprächspartner
man sagen danke deutschland ist leider
nicht flexibel genug des beispiels und
das ist ein schlechter aber nicht eine
prägende erfahrung das kann ich mir
vorstellen und ich wünsche ihnen noch
einen schönen abend wenn sie mögen
scheinen sie morgen aber wieder einen
herzlichen dank an meine gäste und bis
morgen abend noch
[Musik]